hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to three scary games
now it's October which means that it's
spooked ober it's scary
or it's supposed to be scary but what's
good about October is you get more scary
games than you usually would and that is
the same case when it comes down to
indie games so this is rib eye chart
okay hi Charlie how you doing over there
did you uh sorry just rearranging the
furniture here okay oh sorry I'm just
breaking up the place Charlie please
don't be upset with me I'm just trying
to get by I don't know where I am and I
don't know what I'm doing oh hey that's
what that noise was oh I got locked in
here
Oh need to find a way out okay cool
[Music]
all right I think I can do that so long
as the situation is an incredibly dire
and I don't die in a horrible Oh rib I
kill them hmm that's not Charlie's will
make you eat until it hurts
$3.99 give it to the authority delicious
and refreshing there's a lot of
conflicting in from a way to zoom zoom
in on those eyes there's something going
on in those eyes he's got red eyes
he's to get clear eyes hello I mean this
restaurant looks pretty barren and
unappealing but then again revived
Charlie seems a little barren and
unappealing
we'll make you eat until it hurts okay
sure no go in there apparently all right
but where I go what I do how I find a
way out can make a mess of things too
badly oh I found a key Hey look at me
I'm so smart and full of progress and
able to do games and such oh I hate it I
hate it
no I really hate it I probably shouldn't
just charge into this line the fuse box
you say wait
zoom in on that face okay I guess uh oh
okay that a booth oh [ __ ] well [ __ ] me
that well okay all right well we got
through that and that existed and that
happened
ah that's what I was supposed to see
before but then I didn't because I will
I didn't mm-hmm okay so do I gotta go
grab the key again I didn't know that I
can I didn't know that I couldn't just
lollygag and stand in the middle of the
hallway I didn't realize that I mean to
dis kidnap but follow away wait wait
wait wait wait Oh God
wait please oh shoot like that
oh [ __ ] me so is that ribeye Charlie or
Zed just want a ribeye Charlie's lackeys
is that ribeye Charlie or is that
someone that I need to know about either
way can I crouch or something or do
something to prevent my doom I guess I
can be kind of sneaky about it hello can
I close that probably not okay nothing
oh I'm screwed
okay well they're gone now okay so you
Charlie Charlie okay well I got uh can I
leave now
am I done is that all for me rib eye
Charlie rib eye Charlie can you please
give me a reason why I'm here I'm just
kind of confused okay fine then you know
I'll just be on my way
no need to bother me today I'm good oh
[Applause]
why don't you just wait you're just a
sassy sue Oh ain't happy okay so they're
moving together so I'm guessing I just
got to find the fuses I don't even know
how big this place is so how old
okay all right okay so if they're coming
down that way if they don't split up
I'll be all right
if they just don't split up
I'll be just fine okay it's - I'm
assuming I need to get four of these bad
boys if I know something about fuse
boxes in horror or games before is the
magic number my charlie don't mind I
just like the view man you stand on all
your breaks let me go in here nothing
okay
I don't know how big this place is but
I'm gonna go diving into here and for
the best cuz if it's not just the two of
them I'm kind of boned
hello virals no no oh like that thank
you
one more I'm guessing oh [ __ ] don't [ __ ]
no please I don't want to die that must
be the frustrated sound of them not
getting what they want
[Music]
okay well I like that you got a ding
dong bell on you or must be done this
way by Charlie's request of authority
Authority Emergency Management Agency
has issued a seven danger warning for
all locations within our broadcast area
effect of 9:57 p.m. local time all
residents are advised to shelter in
place until further notice
stay inside closed doors and windows
turn off air conditioning or heating
systems of monitor or TV for more
information this message was transmitted
at the request of my authority the
authority okay thank you for that
[Music]
yeah
am i okay might be okay who what not
okay I'm not okay please I don't want to
die not like this
[Music]
suck whoa hey I almost died I'm in
danger okay all right listen listen pal
I don't know where your friend is Oh
your friends over there okay I'm gonna
go the long way around I'm gonna see if
it's in the same places or if it's a
random places I don't know which would
be worse okay this is in the same place
so I'm just assuming that they're all in
the same place maybe the programmer
wasn't able to actually put in and he
sort of ran been missing this into this
and I'm gonna sneak into this one before
they swoop around and then I'm gonna
stay in here until they move I win I win
right it's like it I win yay I escaped
or did it thank you for playing I did it
wels a simple game Oh treats too
I can't read that is a silly one that
was a silly one when you really get down
to it but not bad not bad not bad
actually honestly not bad all right so
this next one is called a wonderful day
for fishing
now don't be thrown off by its cheerful
exterior I have a flaw Oh
it's all water baths the sky reflects
off it scales
we'll eat it up hungry I think anyway oh
okay
yum-o saltwater baths this guy reflects
off its scales
oh I'm good I'll let that work oh um I
am I supposed to eat them am I supposed
to let him go I don't know I oh boy
another one oh whoa a catfish its
whiskers tickle my fingers up that's so
sweet
Oh much much much better okay Wow a Gulf
in its pearly eyes I see its future
demise and by that I mean I see my teeth
reflected in it nom nom nom
oh boy here we go ah I feel the tar
inside me well I'm gonna feel something
else inside me here num num num num I
don't know the differences the
differences what's the difference
between eating it not eating it Oh bear
a disgusting piece of a living witness
we'll get thrown out get out of here
well who needs that nobody not me I
don't need that certainly not this guy
here
okay next oh thank you ah out of its
element this one doesn't have eyes or
not eyes oh you did not sure what I'm
supposed to do here
I don't feel too good after I eat those
okay well is this all I do day in and
day and I just fish up weird fish and
eat them haven't caught any in a boat
there we go ah sand trout a figure in
its mouth scratches trying to escape
good I don't want to eat that it's
already busy eating someone else I don't
want to complete the circle of life
there think I'm okay I think I'm pretty
okay out now I am so weirded out for
some reason I'm just like not okay with
this number one I don't like the ocean
its whiskers poke and pry it my skin why
that's not what that no eat Oh work why
am i read in the middle
why okay all right um whoa a disgusting
piece of living waste well they'd eat it
Oh something's going wrong here and I'm
not 100% sure what there's got to be
like it it's got to be like a pattern to
this right this there's something going
on here like the thing then I'm not
understanding there's something there's
something deeper going on here that's
it's a little bit perturbing it's out of
its element well in my element now okay
it's pearly eyes I see its future demise
well I don't need it then was that what
then what was the deal with me having
black soulless eyes in that one moment I
don't like my smile at all I go what am
I retired mr. clean and I'm out here
Swiss cruise program press it get rid of
it Oh
the larvae arrives beckoning for my
flesh whatever would I eat that I'm
gonna eat it but why would I
here I go yum yum yum in my tum tum tum
poor boy
happened
what is key it pulsates who wants to
become part of me sure I regret
everything I've ever done in my life
am i sinking okay wait no no no no I've
got another all right side of itself
release it that's not helping my
chompers my chompers no that's not how
boats work
that's not how boats sink another one
please it eat it I meant to eat it I
don't know please understand I don't get
it
what's happening defuse Oh bait worm a
living remnant of my failure
let's gonna let that one lie because I
don't know what the hell happened and
frankly I don't know if I want to now
played some more why not ah alright this
is where I am the hard pass this one oh
[ __ ]
I shouldn't have hard passed that one I
probably shouldn't dump the horrible
flesh cube into the river or lake for
body of water that I'm in to come by but
I have no idea what the long-term
objective of this is but it seems to me
seems to be maybe I reached the end oh
you know what maybe it's time to just
accept I'm a oh ok I saw a slice of
something big I didn't like so what just
happened you know I'm not gonna ask any
question anymore because there's too
many questions about this anyway frankly
I need this and I'm gonna say goodbye so
sayonara goodbye' game have fun with
that anyways see ya so welcome to
schizophrenia simulator now this says
that it's not specifically a horror game
but it's meant to be an accurate
simulation of what it's like to live
with schizophrenia I don't like that cat
I don't like that cat at all I don't
like that cat none let's go for it
oh now I've never experienced
schizophrenia obviously but I've never
really understood what the what what the
actual effects are on a person this
disoriented uh it's already ridiculously
disorienting oh my god okay feel dizzy
yeah a little bit yeah just maybe the
perspective of it is super weird on
those why do those look like faces is
that supposed to be like that this is my
pills it must heal my mind I hope ok can
I take them
like guess not okay I got a safe here
some kind of note here everything is
just farther away than they look for you
to read testing new efficient medicine
to cure schizophrenia test medication
number 137 uses this new special
mechanic to neutralize the neuro
desynchronisation in frontal lobes
hippocampus and temporal lobes
neurocognitive neurocognitive deficits
in the mesolimbic pathway will be
balanced with dopamine supplements
caution it is a test medicine if you
feel discomfort or any side effects
please do call dr. blue Lehrer okay dr.
Blair dr. Blair I don't feel so good dr.
Blair little er Oh hate this Oh lock it
good thing I locked my doors in my own
house I wouldn't want to feel unsafe in
any part of this hi I guess I'll answer
that hello hi howdy how are you doing oh
voice in my head again maybe you should
take your pills
oh yeah that's normal yeah it's what we
had definitely normal that's fine okay
you think that that was someone talking
to me on the phone and that wasn't just
something in my head feeling anxious
yeah a little bit yeah well I didn't
close that door I didn't close that door
I don't know what the hell's happening
here but I don't feel so good I want to
paint something and relax okay that's a
good that's a perfectly reasonable idea
oh god it's so Diaz my Studios upstairs
is it the locked one it might be the
locked one oh my god it's so
uncomfortable it's just that kind of
unsettling that just puts you off
everything seems wrong I mean I played
games in high field-of-view before but
it's never been just completely lead
disorienting I thought I heard something
key
No he oh my god
key no key no key there we go okay got
it
time to go unlock the door the safe safe
door that I keep safe because I keep it
locked all the time I always lock them
door I don't feel like relaxing I'm
gonna paint some happy little demons I
don't like this picture want to throw it
away press you to renew paint whoa gone
just like that
that's better scrubbed from existence I
need more paint doctor told me to use
more colors I should find more paints I
might have something
TV room downstair you got it bingo bango
here I go good no problem no problema I
got paints all over the house painting
the toilet painting the bathtub painting
the shower paint my fridge I got paint
everywhere it's like living in paint cuz
all the color can you see all the color
around me tons of it paint no paint ah
okay I got it
got blood I got poop I got peepee I got
all the colors everyone you never knew
everyone I'd never need anyway - baby I
need to take one more pillow
in my room oh come up back away slowly
from this I don't like that I don't like
that at all back away slowly
okay just pop a pill something was on my
computer I hope it will help doctor told
me to eat more sugar time to go to the
kitchen what are you gonna paint
I just want to paint a happy little tree
it's still there okay huh I don't like
that I don't like that one bit I don't
like that one iota whoa nothing nothing
about that is good okay can I play like
a nice game a happy game
Apple I have another no that's it okay
thank you I feel worse I can't move I
can't I can't move
oh my mind is my head is so heavy
was it sound yes what is that sound
sound is it real I don't know did
something break I didn't see anything
why are you making me freak out is that
a face I don't know
that doors closed it wasn't closed
before I'm gonna go paint the sound was
in my bathroom oh what's in the mirror
no no no no what is in my head they're
driving me crazy I need to rest now
oh okay go to bed
oh I'm just gonna lay my head to rest
I'm gonna go to bed time to bed
no painting for me no relaxing happening
you're still there good great anyway
closed door look here clothes alright I
can close the door I didn't do that I
didn't do that
vertigo yeah no joke close this okay
Oh tough we're sleepy I'll go to bed lay
my head to rest okay oh [ __ ]
alright this ice I'd like to slide into
my bed sound somebody's playing piano I
need to check I don't remember seeing a
piano have a piano
Nana's done worse swing what did I do
who are you my head stop being a dick
leave me alone oh you're done now okay
knock you're back oh yes okay thank you
your hatred fuels me I think pianos done
okay well that was fun yeah time's up
for what for what I need to wash my face
with cold water in the bathroom okay
here I go
watch my faith even though the mirror
had something else on it you know
doesn't I don't like to skip like it
please me I'm Gumby
I'm very uncommon he's gonna be in the
mirror again that is called it mirror
mirror mirror on the wall I needed a
medicine that isn't oh okay I'll take my
medicine
you gotta get the medicine okay I'm sure
that overdosing on this is probably not
a bad thing
crap oh crap crappy indeed okay take a
pill
alright test med number one what is one
buy me don't just do that that's the
game I play on you cuz it's behind you
run run okay anyway I need Oh to calm my
mind bad bad bad bad yeah who's already
here okay they are well that's not good
are they they're already here just dive
in oh the some I'm doing a backflip I
think what the [ __ ] hell hi okay no
no one is here I'm not sure about that
one I think I think someone might
actually be here I think oh [ __ ] okay
who's here who's they who's they is that
my voice can I paint I'd like to paint
hello can I start over how do I get rid
of you okay alright well that's nice
well no okay apparently no oh that's
crooked I like that but that's for other
reasons all right well I could eat an
apple again that'd be nice maybe I could
try to do that didn't know I was
downstairs and now I'm here okay thank
you I'll just pop another pill and be on
my way
okay all right well that was how did I
get here
good question I don't remember oh okay
that could have caused me to fall and
die oh this is the game that we're gonna
complain [ __ ]
they're already here they're already
here they're already here they are here
here is where they are they're here if I
see you oh they're here apparently
they're here
did you guys know that they're here wait
this stores closed by system oh okay oh
I guess I'm playing I don't know where I
am
Oh
Oh some I think we've left the realm of
reality some I think we're in the realm
of alternate reality all green-screen am
i a youtuber oh boy
Oh 3lakhs story you don't need to do
that Oh
oh oh ooh
that's probably I shouldn't just stand
here okay all right well now that I I
know how scary you is okay well I'll
just let them absorb into my body okay
oh do not do that to me I don't know how
am I gonna find three keys here I can't
even find Wow
[Music]
I see something over here I don't know
what the the audio is saying it's it's
shifting between a few different voices
something was talking about ESP there oh
is that a key all right well okay all
right don't mind me I got the key all
right
I don't know what that means but I got
one did I get the only key or did I get
the key is there one of three Kaiser or
what is the dealio with the key I don't
even know where the center of the is
that where I that's another key no is
that another key well hi oh hi no that's
not that that's the same one where is it
is it I can't tell I don't know where
I've been and where I haven't been I got
no landmarks I got no identification
hello what are you oh do not cut me off
do not coming up do not cut me up what
are you what are you what are you doing
what are you doing over there hey what
are you doing hello what are you
screwing over there okay never mind
you're gonna cut me off okay never mind
okay you have fun with whatever the [ __ ]
you were doing let's just go on my merry
way
hip-hip-hooray here I go what is that I
don't know what that is I'm just walking
towards a big blue ah oh okay apparently
this is the experience that we're gonna
be going through we're just gonna be
losing our minds which I guess is the
whole thing about this game X oh that's
a key
okay Oh dramatic okay all right then I
don't know why but all right so I've got
two keys I need one more I don't know if
my whole progress is gonna reset once I
get this lat
or if I die before I get the last one
but it seems a little more difficult to
die so there is something to all of this
you guys are both faster and slower than
I think you are hope there we go that's
what those guys are shockingly fast okay
thank you for this got the key
all right know why I don't do that when
I have to run away from that that is not
okay and don't show me that clock that I
said I didn't like because it's crooked
and I don't do crooked okay thank you
for that this place is just disorienting
it's just all disorienting where am i
where am i going on anymore okay here's
where I am
can I can I take my nap my Apple I just
like to get me munch munch on a sweet
Apple that'd be great okay oh that's
nice that's real nice thank you for that
can I go home never mind I am awake
thanks God it was just a dream thanks
God thanks big guy or girl I don't know
that was a horrible dream yeah Kim I'm
dehydrated I can't imagine it I can't
imagine what it'd be like to dream if
you had schizophrenia somehow that feels
like it would be worse than reality wait
is it different there's something
different about that no it's the same
okay goodbye I'm fine I'll just close
this door goodbye it's weird I've gotten
used to this point of view
okay that was delicious feels good feels
good man feels good so what about that
so what about feeling good
all right don't feel so good that rumbly
in my tumbly said i don't feel so good
what is that
no mom why do you always call now mom
the one time when I'm recording it's
always when I'm recording mom I can't
talk right now mom
okay barely not let me at least text my
mom hopefully nothing happens okay I
don't know what to do do I go back to
bed and I don't want to criticize me I'm
going through some [ __ ] but I need to
get I need to fix that run no I'm why
why is there wavy wacky waving
inflatable arm-flailing
oh wait wait wait
square triangle circle Hey so four three
four three zero eight four three one no
[Music]
wait four three four three one eight
maybe eight three four
I'm not stupid here four three zero
eight or four three money I'm nine oh my
god oh my god what is I can't do any now
okay I
where am I I don't know I have no idea
my demons
[Music]
one well that's a load of [ __ ] well
that's a load of poopy doobie my
personality is sealed in here well
that's just a load of Garbo but forever
okay because you are you in just stupid
code really you're gonna let the game
and go worldwide about 1% of the
population is diagnosed with
schizophrenia created by choppy pine
25th September 2018 okay then well then
does that mean that was that the only
ending wait no but I but that's stupid
well that's dumb there's no oh God
[ __ ] a duck of course god damn it of
course it's gonna it's gonna come to aw
of course it's gonna come down to that
of course of course it's gonna come down
to that that makes me mad that makes me
very very mad that makes me very very
very mad but either way I guess that is
just how that goes
hard don't like that cat so that was
three scary games I'm not gonna go back
through the whole thing and just to see
if I can get the code because I don't
even know if that was possible but
frankly yeah frankly I'll end it there
just because it did have a good
experience in there it was a little slow
paced and the pacing was a little off
throughout it but it still was a good
experience and I still had a good time
and I think it was alright but even so
man there's a perk my bubbles so thank
you everybody so much for watching if
you've got other scary games or other
weird games you want me to assemble in a
three game package let me know down in
the comments below thank you everybody
so much for watching and as always I
will see
you in the next video
[Music]